So, our job is to help
you do a data detox
and that's reduce the amount of data
that is out there about you.
But you decide
that this is the important part.
Gal Ringel,
thank you so much for being on my show.
How are you?
Good morning.
I'm great.
Thank you very much for having me.
Thank you for taking time to do this.
There's a lot to talk about.
I've been following you for a while,
and I'm a big fan.
I'd love to spend our 20 minutes
talking about your journey
from a technologist to investment,
to business world, now to CEO,
talking about that
non-linear career pathway
that comes up so much
from thought leaders
like yourself on the show.
And then I would also love to,
to talk a little bit about
the most recent series A investment
that you raised
completely through Zoom.
So, we have a lot to cover,
but let's go all the way back.
Gal Ringel, who are you?
So, I'd love to share a few words.
I mean, I think I'm biased,
but I think I have a really diverse
and I would call it a strange career.
So, it all started like 20,
25 something years ago,
when I was 8 years old,
where I've started
to write code and hack stuff.
Yes, I know,
it's on a really young age.
But this is what got me eventually
to [--] to the 8200 units,
in the Israeli army.
I'm sure you're probably familiar
with that unit, right?
Yes. Yes.
I got to be there myself.
But tell me, how did you get
to start coding at eight years old?
How does that even happen?
So, I'm a gamer,
I used to play Counterstrike
back in the days.
And actually this got me
to land my first job
in one of the leading
gaming companies in Israel.
We actually did
LAN parties and, you know,
back in the days
where people brought
their computers and big screens.
And I was basically in charge
of running all the networks
and all the server.
This is how I learned networks
and routers
and even to code some of the things
on the Counterstrike servers.
Wow.
So, yeah, it's a bizarre story,
but this is how I got to the coding world
and this is what developed later on
to start hacking stuff.
So, now, when you're
saying hacking stuff,
give me a little bit of context.
Because when I'm imagining
an eight year old hacking stuff,
that doesn't really add up in my mind.
What does that actually mean to you?
So, I'm talking about around
the age of 12, not eight.
This is where I start to hack stuff
and I'm talking about security hacking.
So,
back in the days
when the Internet started,
the Internet didn't have any
proper security in place.
So, I started to
test my skills.
I don't know if you remember,
but once we were downloading things
to like PPP servers
before [--] and that
world.
So, we started to hack stuff
and, you know, train my skills.
Yeah.
So, this is how it started.
Wow. Okay.
So, you're 12 years old,
you're into gaming,
you're into hacking and coding,
you get into the 8200 unit,
you spend a few years as a captain
in that unit,
so, you're really honing
your technology skills
both in terms of, you know,
leading teams but also hands on learning.
And then you make this interesting
quick transition to the business world.
So, again, a nonlinear career pathway.
How do you find yourself then
going into investments?
And I believe you were in Verizon, right?
And you were an investment principal
in various places,
how do you get there?
So, it's a really good story.
I mean, after 10 years of hands on
developing or dealing with technology,
I just woke up one day and decided
that I want to change something
in my career path.
I was really good in technology,
but I didn't want to take that
to the next level and, you know,
be a VP R&D, or a CTO.
I decided I want to take my tech skills
and leverage that on the business side.
But as you mentioned,
I had to go study that somehow.
So,
I had my first
computer science degree,
but I didn't want to go
and do MBA back then.
So, yeah.
So, I found myself joining
the venture capital community.
I started with Nielsen,
the market research company,
for two years
doing early stage investment.
And then I moved on to Verizon Ventures,
as you mentioned,
doing later stage investments.
And I think what's so special
about that four and a half years
is that I had a really
amazing chance to get a glimpse
into the startup ecosystem by investing
in early stage, later stage companies
and to learn business skills,
product, marketing, hiring,
I sit in board meetings,
and eventually in foreign affairs.
I had the chance to invest
in 20 companies.
So, I saw them developing
and advancing
from the very early stage
to the very growth stage.
And I think for me,
an amazing experience
to acquire a lot of skillset
that I'm using,
that I'm putting into action right now.
So, you pretty much created
your own form of MBA, right?
It's a really interesting path
that you spend
quite a few years in technology.
It's not like one or two, right?
It's many years in technology.
You reach a certain level.
You are comfortable enough to go
and execute on a lot of these issues.
But then you find yourself in a fork
in the road where you have to decide,
am I going to be a VP, R&D/CTO?
Or do I actually want to be
on the business side of things
and know how to actually run a company?
And then you decide to go
into the investment field
and now most recently,
you're running your own startup.
So, tell me all about that,
because, first of all,
I love what you're doing with Mine.
I think that the story
of how you raise the money now
is fascinating.
But tell me a little bit about
how you moved from VC
to creating a startup.
So, after foreign affairs
doing investment deals,
I practically decided
that I'm ready to go back and do
what I'm really passionate about,
which to start my own company.
And so, I grabbed my two friends.
One of them, our CTO Gal Golan,
who and I served together in 8200 unit.
And we're good friends for six years.
He was actually my trainer.
So, everything that I know
in my cybersecurity side
is thanks to him.
And the third co-founder is Kobi Nissan,
who I met during my VC career.
He worked with Saban Ventures
and when the three of us sat together,
we knew that we want to solve something
that is very painful for us personally.
And after a few meetings,
we quickly discover that the three of us
really understands personal data.
And how valuable and precious is it
to each one of us on the personal level.
But we quickly realize that
three of us dealt with personal data
of different people from all kinds of
different angles through our career.
And we quickly realized that
we know how easily
our personal data can be exploited,
exploited against us as people.
And this is how we thought about Mine.
We knew that we want to
bring a consumer product
that can help people understand
what companies are doing with their data.
But not only that,
to take an action
and to do something about it.
And I'm talking about the end of 2017
where the GDPR was not legislated.
And as VC, we started to research that,
and we quickly identified that the GDPR
has made a history in the Internet
or changed the history of the Internet
because it's actually defined,
all personal data is our own asset
and it gave us powerful rights.
But here is a funny story.
We knew that that regulation
wouldn't be used by people
because it's very hard and complex.
So, to prove that,
we went all around Europe
asking people in the street.
Like we grabbed people in the street
and asked them whether
they heard about the GDPR
and whether they exercise
any of their rights.
And can you guess what was the answer?
100% no.
What is GDPR?
So, most of them did hear about it
because all they see,
all they saw was the
freaking Cookie consent
everywhere in every site, right,
where you need to allow all the time.
But none of them could actually
try to exercise these rights.
Some of them did try,
like a small portion
said that they did want to try,
but it was very complex.
So, this is how we knew that
we have to make it accessible
to millions of people
because it's a very powerful right.
And this is how Mine started.
Right.
So, give me a little bit of context
for those who don't still understand
the magnitude of the problem
of private data and personal data.
What is the trend
and how compromised is our
personal data in 2020?
So, it's a very good question.
So, data privacy
or data protection in 2021,
we believe that the entire
market is shift
from privacy into what we identified
as a data ownership.
And why do I say that?
If you think about privacy,
if we wanted to protect our privacy,
we had to prevent from our personal data
to be shared with others, right?
To install a VPN
or to use a dedicated browser.
But all of those solutions
actually change our online experience,
right?
If you use a VPN,
to log into your bank account,
you would immediately get blocked, right?
So, it actually changed,
changing our online experience.
So, we wanted to design a product
that blends into your day-to-day
and doesn't change any,
any of your behavior.
I mean, we want to sign up to services,
we want to purchase things online,
we want to give our data,
but we identify that the problem is
to manage our data
on an ongoing basis.
And just to give you one
interesting insight,
can you guess how many companies
hold the average user data?
And I'm talking about
companies that have
actively collected your data
from sign ups, purchases,
things that you are doing
on your day to day, not passive.
How many companies have that?
That's a question?
Wow.
I mean, as a developer myself,
I would imagine that at least
90% of the companies
that I'm actively seeing in my day to day
have a lot of personal information
about me.
So, we actually have the number.
So, the
worldwide average
digital footprint consist of
350 companies.
So, 350 companies?
350 companies that's holding
your set of data.
It can be email plus any other thing,
passport, social security number,
date of birth.
And in the US, by the way,
it's even higher. It's 550.
550 companies.
Wow, that's just scary.
Yeah.
So, going back to your original question.
We quickly identified that the problem is
managing all data on an ongoing basis
and how we can make sure
to leave our data
only when we actually still using it.
And this is why we develop MIne.
So, Mine in [--],
is smart data assistant
that blends into your day to day
and allows you to always know
where your data is
and who has what about you.
Now Gal, I do want to make a distinction.
It's important for me
to make a distinction here
because I think that,
it almost feels like the world
is now split into two types of people.
There's the people that love the fact
that their data is being shared
and is being used by services,
and then there's the other people
that feel like okay,
we're losing our privacy,
companies are going to misuse the data.
And obviously, I think we can both agree
that it's somewhere in the middle.
Right?
We want to enjoy having services,
leverage their knowledge about me,
so that they can personalize
my experience, whether it's offering me
sharing rides to my
workplace or whatever,
what is the next good purchase for me.
Obviously, there is
the misuse of data, right?
So, getting for example,
my election, my voting habits
to advertise for campaigns.
Now, I think that
what you're doing here is your,
what I love about what you're doing
is you're taking back control
over choosing where do I want my data
to be stored. Right?
It's not an all or nothing approach of,
I don't want my data
to be shared anywhere.
And we understand that
our data is going to be shared.
I want to be able to control
where it's going to be shared
in the world, right?
Yeah.
I am so happy
that you mentioned that because
to give back control to users,
we call it to bring you back the choice.
And what is so nice
about our product is that,
as you mentioned,
the world today is a binary world.
It's either we share our data
or we don't.
But what we wanted to do with Mine,
is give you the choice to decide.
So, the first phase is to
basically understand
who has what.
Right?
This is the accessibility,
the 350 companies
that most people don't have any idea.
And after you do have that understanding,
you have the choice to
take it back,
to take your data back.
And this is the control
that you mentioned.
And to give you all the data
that you need,
all the information in order to take
an informed choice,
and in order to understand
what services you need to delete
and what services you need to keep.
Because you either using them
or trust them,
but you have the choice.
We are not deciding for you.
But we will be there
to alert you all the time
that it's changing.
Because today you can use a service
and in a few weeks
you can stop using that.
So, why give them the chance
to keep holding your data.
Because every day
there's a new data breach
and a new privacy scandal.
And you mentioned the election.
So, our job is to help you
do a data detox,
and that's reduce the amount of data
that is out there about you.
But you decide,
and this is the important part.
I think that's just remarkable.
I know we can talk about hours.
We can talk about data for hours.
And I think that what you're doing
is insanely relevant.
I'm guessing that
it's an exponential growth,
the amount of data
that is being stored on us.
Right?
With every new platform that comes up,
we're inventing new data types
that are being shared about us.
And I remember distinctly
with Cambridge Analytica,
when the report came out in 2016,
just how much knowledge
they had on so many people.
You know, things
your risk-takes that
that the person never even shared,
they never even necessarily
shared with them
what their favorite color is.
But they use your risk-takes
to think about that.
But Gal, I have to spend a few minutes
talking about your most recent
series A raise.
Because it's phenomenal
to be able to do it.
It's even more phenomenal
to do it all over Zoom.
So, tell me what happened over there.
So, this is a really interesting story,
because in the middle of it,
somehow covid started.
But if I take you a few months back.
After we raised our seed round
in early 2019,
we worked for the entire year in stealth
to develop our product.
And when we felt it's ready
to hit the market,
we did our official launch in Europe,
but also in Productant.
We were very surprised
by the amazing traction that we received
in a very short period of time.
We actually won the first place
up of the day and week,
and second place up the month
on Productant.
And somehow it got a lot of attention
back to us from investors.
It turns out that a lot of investors
are monitoring Productant.
And so, we started to speak
with a lot of investors.
And I'm talking about
the end of January this year.
So, you know, I started to
jump on calls with investors,
I was not raising my series A,
just to share our story, right?
To share the vision,
what we are after,
and to develop relationships
with those investors.
And then covid arrived,
I'm talking about March 1st,
covid hits Europe probably, right?
And three weeks later
in the US as well.
And I actually felt how the entire VC,
the entire worldwide VC community
is like shut down
or getting into a worldwide freeze.
So, similarly to us being locked down
in the first lock down,
I felt how the entire VC community
got into a worldwide freeze
and it's really understandable.
Most of them had to assess
their portfolio damages
and to quickly develop
a plan to help the companies in it.
I have to say that, you know,
it was a very special time.
I'm a senior associate
in an early stage VC firm in Palo Alto.
And I distinctly remember the confusion
of what's unraveling.
And here we are,
we have active investments,
we have LP's,
we have money that is
ready to be deployed into the market,
and all of a sudden
we think to ourselves,
what is our responsibility
and what do we do.
And one of the things that,
one of the key questions
you start asking yourself is,
well, how do we make sure that even,
like how long is this going to last?
And assuming that our companies
are not going to make any money
until this thing ends,
what is the runway that they have
and how can we support them?
And it was all a very confusing time.
So, I can only imagine
from a startup's perspective,
what does that mean
to now potentially go into
a series A investments.
So, you are very right.
And luckily for me,
I could play both sides.
Because I came from the VC community,
and now, I'm doing my own thing.
And I actually felt that.
And you mentioned
that you also worked in a VC,
so you know the financial model
behind VCs.
And you probably know that
we are raising funds for nine years.
Right?
So, I quickly understand it.
Covid, even if it's going
to last two years,
it's a really small bump in the tail.
Right?
It's not so hard for the VCs.
So, I just knew that
we have to hold down a little bit
and give the VC some time to digest
and to develop the plan they need
to save some of the companies.
Because some industries
were really affected by covid,
for example, the travel industry.
So, we started speaking
with those VC's,
develop the relationship.
We knew that we have to stay a little bit
to give them enough time
to develop their own strategies.
But as you saw, most of VC
were quickly back in business, right?
I guess it took, what,
three months?
And luckily for us,
the covid was actually increased
the need for data privacy
and data protection.
You probably heard about
contact tracing, location tracing.
So, privacy was again in the major news
and it was really good for us.
And one of the investors
that we were talking to,
great investors,
we had like monthly update calls
during that period of time.
And around June,
we were lucky enough,
to even around May,
we were lucky enough
to get a term sheet.
And around June
to close the entire round
completely over Zoom.
Everything though Zoom, start to finish.
The leading partner, Darian Shirazi,
he never met us in person.
And we had another two VCs,
one from Germany
and another CVC from the US,
MassMutual and E.ventures,
they never met us.
And, you know,
coming from a VC perspective,
a VC background,
I never thought that investment deals
can be done remotely.
You always have to feel the people
and to meet them in person,
with something and the vibe
in like feeling them on their flesh.
Yeah. 100%.
So, it was a really
interesting experience to me.
I guess covid teach us that
we need to do business remotely.
We have to, because the world
have to keep moving on.
And I guess,
I experienced that firsthand
was a really
interesting experience for me.
I don't know if there will ever be
a time again
where deals of this magnitude
will be made entirely through Zoom.
I can't imagine a society
where people deploy millions of dollars
without wanting to meet
the other person in person.
But Gal, I thank you
for all the amazing work
that you're doing with Mine.
Thank you for
everything you taught me
through this 20 Minute Leaders.
I really enjoyed it
and I can't wait to continue following
the company in your journey.
It sounds really, really amazing.
But before we leave,
I have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Wow. It's a challenging one.
I would say calm,
it's the first one.
Maybe fearless.
This is something that the 8200 unit
teach us, that you can do anything
that you want.
And I would say something
that would surprise some people,
but funny.
So, I guess that the people
that know me personally would say that.
So, yeah.
So calm, fearless and funny.
Gal, toda raba.
Thank you very, very much.
Best of luck
with everything that you're doing.
And I can't wait to keep in touch.
Thank you.
Thank you very much,
and I really invite you all to join,
saymine.com
and just take ownership
of your personal data
and really do something
for the first time.
I love it.
Gal, toda raba. Bye bye.